Speaker 1: We have been talking now for
over a week about the possible unintended
or maybe intended, but unexpected or maybe
intended and expected consequences of what
we believe is the forthcoming Supreme Court
ruling overturning Roe v Wade. And we said,
well, they'll they'll probably
try coming for gay marriage.
They'll probably try coming for copayment, for
contraceptives. They're going to try these things.
And we've since heard from the Texas governor of
the Republican governor of Texas, Greg Abbott,
that they want to come before the Supreme
Court decision that says the children of
undocumented immigrants have to be allowed to
go to public school. They want to end that.
And we've heard all these different things. I have
a very, very dangerous example of this for you
today. Anti-choice activist Abby Johnson appeared
with radical right conspiracy theorist Stu Peters
and previewed the idea of executions of abortion
providers. Right. If you believe in the death
penalty and you believe abortion is murder and
you believe that it is the abortion provider
that is committing the murder, then it would
almost logically follow that. You would say,
well, we've got to put the abortion providers
to death. Now, as a reminder, Stu Peters,
the guy on the left of your screen, if you're
watching today, he is the same guy who once had
either the flu or COVID, and he claimed that he
was targeted by a bioweapon because he's against
vaccines instead of just being like, well,
actually, the simplest thing is I got the
thing. I'm not vaccinated against that. That may
actually makes a lot more sense. Okay. So it's
Stu Peters interviewing Abby Johnson when they
say this stuff, we should be listening to them.
Speaker 4: Okay. So abortion is illegal
in my state. And that's great when Roe is
overturned. But what does that actually mean?
Speaker 6: It means that it's murder. It's
murder. And we need a governor.
Speaker 4: That it needs to
be treated like murder.
Speaker 6: That's right.
And we need a governor with the balls to stand
up and say that I will bulldoze every single
Planned Parenthood facility in my state. I
will bulldoze any facility that facilitates
this murder of unborn babies.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now,
this is not this is not merely something that
they say. There have been dozens or hundreds
of acts of vandalism, violence and terror at
family planning clinics across the country. And
abortion doctors have also been murdered.
Okay. So these are not idle threats. And
listen to the words that they're using.
Speaker 6: Preborn, real living people.
I will make it a criminal offense to fund anybody
that does this. And if you if you're found out
funding murder or carrying out murder, you will
be executed. Wow. That's what needs to happen.
They need to be indicted and they need
to be tried and they need to be executed.
Speaker 1: Now, before we go on to the
Civil War part that they talk about.
There are some on the radical anti-choice right.
Who say. Try and execute the abortion providers.
There are others who go further and say execute
the mother as well, because ultimately she's
consenting to the procedure. That's that's a
controversial position. Even among the right.
Some on the right say, no, the women are the
victims, so you don't go after them. And there's
it's a fraught question because politically there
are problems on both sides of that. It's a crazy
conversation. I'm acting like it's a rational
conversation. It's not. But certainly execute
the abortion doctors they mostly feel pretty good
about. Let's move on to the next section now.
Speaker 4: It's a war over slavery, right?
Why? Because there was a group of people
who were seen and treated as subhuman. And
right now in our country, there is a group
of people who are seen and treated as subhuman.
Speaker 1: Now understand she's talking about
fetuses as a group of people. That is
part of how they identify with this issue.
Speaker 4: I mean, we are in our society
at war. But. Maybe it means more than that,
and maybe it should. If there was ever a
time, if there was ever an issue for us to.
I'll actually go to war over. Wow. You know, if
there was ever a time when this becomes a legal.
And and if these clinics tried to
remain open and kill these babies.
Then maybe direct action needs to take place.
Speaker 5: That's right.
Speaker 1: They're talking about a civil war.
They're talking about violence, by the way,
at the bottom of the screen. I don't know if you
can see this. It says the underbelly of the Soros
plan to kill American babies. So it's never a good
story on these right wing channels unless you can
somehow involve George Soros in it as well. This
is the right wing wet dream, killing abortion
providers legally through the death penalty. Okay.
And a civil war. This is they're not kidding.
And hopefully this will never happen. But they're
telling the truth that they would like to see it
happen. And we know there is willingness to
do violence, to do to do murder. From the
anti-choice. Right. They've killed people.
Dr. George Tiller, family planning. Doctor,
we've talked about it. We covered it when it took
place. I don't remember what year it was. Was it
2012? Let me let me be clear on that. George
Tiller. Let me make sure I know. 29 sorry, 29.
In Wichita, Kansas, George Tiller was shot dead by
anti-choice activists. And I recently appeared on
the The Daily Wire's Michael Knowles Show again to
talk about this issue of abortion. And we're going
to be publishing that soon. And you will see the
way in which these people talk about this issue
incites violence. It incites violence. And
this issue is not going away anytime soon.